hello my name is Caleb bindi and welcome
back to game review today I wanted to
take a look at a rapid game and not from
the tournament you might be expecting of
course at the end of 2019 we had the
world rapid and blitz Championships but
a lot of people might not know that the
first rapid championship was actually
played all the way back in 1988 and it
was kind of unique in the fact that they
did one of them and then there were some
controversies surrounding it so they
actually didn't do another one until the
2000s and that's the format that that we
now have today there were a couple in
between but eventually we did arrive at
the world rapid Championships as we now
know them however in this 1988 world
rapid championship Anatoly Karpov was
the favorite and Garry Kasparov actually
declined to play which is why they
didn't do another one for for quite a
while with that of mainz Anatoly Karpov
did win the entire event and of course
that made him I guess the first world
rapid championship a the first world
rapid champion although at the time I
think they called it the active chess
champion which was slightly slightly
strange anyways though today I wanted to
take a look at one of his games from
that tournament where he played Roman
gingili so in this one I told had the
black pieces and let's see how he
handled it
he chose the Carroll Khan one of my
favorite openings we see d4 d5 II takes
d5 C takes d5 Bishop d3 knight c6 c3 and
Knight f6 and this is the exchange
Carrick on it's one of the most common
ways for white to play and very often
you'll see white play this move h3 here
and the idea of this move is it's going
to be slightly uncomfortable for black
to develop this bishop this is one of
the main lines these days and I think
this is one of the ways that that white
really pushes for an edge in modern
chess that with that in mind though the
prescribed way of playing ends h3 back
in the 1980s I think it was to play a
move like Queen c7 or move like 'if I've
breaking in the center taking advantage
of these dark squares so the white
players at the time
well why would I allow all that I can
simply play Bishop f4 stop all of these
moves and force black to do something
else of course the downside to this is
that you give black the g4 square so you
see kind of the give-and-take already in
the game
gingy ice really chose to play Bishop f4
so Karpov developed his Bishop the queen
is attacked so it can comes out to be
three hitting a b7 pawn simply queen c8
defends the threat this Knight comes out
to d2 we now see II 6 Knight gf3 Bishop
e7 castles and castles both sides simply
getting developed and now Rick a e1 was
White's choice this Bishop actually
comes back to h5 and this move might
might look a little bit strange at first
but the ideas is very very simple the
idea is that this bishop in structures
like this even with a pawn on e3
sometimes the LightSquared Bishop is
almost always White's most powerful
minor piece so you'll see black quite
often do anything you can to trade this
Bishop off the board and that's exactly
what's going on here with Bishop h5
Karpov is aiming to play Bishop g6 to
contest this Bishop and force it to
trade itself off white tries to prevent
this by playing Knight e5 keeping an eye
on the g6 square but Karpov is not so
easily swayed he trades this knight and
continues with Bishop g6 anyways white
takes this opportunity not to try to
save the bishop because if the bishop
can't be on d3 it's really not quite as
powerful as White would like it to be so
instead we see the trade doubling
Black's pawns and now this Queen
actually retreats all the way back to d1
and now we kind of fully understand that
the character of the position both sides
that have made some trades made some
decisions already and it's very very
clear what both sides want to do of
course we have a Karlsbad like structure
on the Queen side here meaning white has
these four pawns all lined up seemingly
very very solid and in the meanwhile
black has a deep pond and
and a beep on but no seep on so what
this means is it's the prime opportunity
for black to launch what's called a
minority attack minority attack of
course is when you attack upon majority
with a pawn minority so black is gonna
use these two pawns to try and create
some weaknesses on the queenside
you can expect to move like b4 aiming
for B takes c3 and if this be pawn will
recapture the C pawn is now very very
weak on a half-open file so what does
this leave for white well you can simply
look at the placement of his pieces and
the the idea becomes pretty obvious this
Queen just retreated back to d1 aiming
at the Kings side this rook ends at the
center and more specifically the King
site side of the center this rook
already placed on the F file aims at the
center this Bishop aims at the King this
Knight ready to come in to attack the
King White's gonna play on the Kings
side and so black wastes no time
launches his minority attack with b5
white starts with the move rook III
black continues with a 5 and now white
plays h4 and so both sides are fully
committed to to these plans as they
should be black continues with b4 what
continues with g4 and now it's a very
interesting decision that that Karpov
has to make here there's a couple of
different ways you can treat this
tension on the Queen side one way you
can handle it is to take on c3 and this
would be a perfectly valid way to play
rook takes c3 would likely be the
response and now rather than a weakness
on c3 white has a weakness on b2 to
contend with to imagine move like Queen
a6 and something like King g2 and this
is going to be the the weak point in the
white camp
that that black is going to aim for
however if you notice though this Bishop
is placed on a very nice diagonal which
for the moment prevents any black rooks
from coming straight to b8 so perhaps
this is one reason why our pub chose
another way to deal with this tension
and that is playing a for Karpov wants
to attack the pawn chain at its
wants to play a three get rid of this
annoying b2 pond and then break through
on the C file in the a file which I like
this idea quite a bit it does give a
wipe the opportunity to capture on b4
also gaining this pun structure but it
would activate the black bishop
ever-so-slightly
instead we see h5 white just continues
his attack on the King side and now
Karpov continues with a3 just simply
going right for the throat attacking the
space of the pawn chain as soon as
possible and this is a very interesting
dynamic that you you see when both sides
have plans on opposite sides of the
board that they kind of ignore each
other the reason for that is sometimes
when you touch your pawns or touch your
pieces on the side of the board where
your opponent's attacking you it only
serves to make more weaknesses or to
quicken their play so both sides are
ignoring each other trying to get their
plan to break through first and here we
see white actually go for C takes b4
when in fact a move like H takes g6
might have also been another way to play
just continuing to ignore nor the
threats but we see a takes b4 here
Karpov actually makes a pretty
significant mistake the best move by far
is to take on b2 opening up this a file
and allowing the black pieces to really
be active perhaps he was worried about a
move like a3 defending this b4 upon when
it's a little bit unclear if black is
gonna be in time to hold on to this pawn
and break through on the Queen's side if
they simply move like Knight d7 you're
gonna want to move this Bishop out of
the way and after we we clear up some
tension over here and Bishop f6 it's a
little unclear how white is going to
pick up this pawn when our bishops very
very quickly coming into the game of
course there are other ways to play as
well for example if white chooses to
leave this Bishop here and takes on a g6
we can capture and after takes takes and
takes let's say Queen b3 trying to pick
up this pawn we always have tactical
means of defending it so a takes b2 was
by far the best move instead though
Karpov chooses Bishop takes b4 and
this really gives white an opportunity
to play first of all h6 really eyeing
these dark squares around the King black
doesn't panic he just responds with
Ricky it and now be three was the key
move that that white missed here keeping
things closed on the Queen side would
have been far more preferable than
allowing black to take on b2 of course
this does give blacks some time to rima
new ver as pieces but it's well worth it
to keep black locked out of the Queen
side instead though we CH takes g7 this
Knight comes to d7 and now after rook b3
we see Bishop e7 keeping this Bishop on
the board this R it comes to c3 this
fish this Queen comes to b7 and now
after first Rick c7 then Queen b5 only
now white plays b3 but the problem here
for white is that he had two problems to
solve and let's go back to two H takes
g7 this move forces black to play 97 but
the problem is 97 is actually making a
threat Knight takes e5 is a very very
significant move that white has to look
out for you very much don't want to
allow this trade the same time though
you very much don't want to allow pawn
takes b2 and so there are two problems
to solve here and really white only had
one chance to solve them and that was by
taking on a3 you use this tempo on the
bishop in order to solve all of your
problems at once instead though with
what we see with rook b3 Bishop e7 rook
c3 queen bee 7 Rick c7 Queen b5 there's
no way to solve both problems at the
same time white chose to solve the
problem of 8x b2 but Knight takes e5 d
takes e5 is actually so so powerful for
black that he's simply winning the game
now
the bishop was needed to attack this
King now there's simply Queen before
being played King g2 trying to use this
h-file rook AC 8 Merc a7 Queen D for
this very very nice central square for
the Queen is available due to the
absence of this dark square Bishop rook
a4 and now the pawns start falling off
the board
or white we see a few more moves g5 this
Queen comes up to be too and really this
this queen is just collecting all of the
pawns and this King comes back to h1 we
see King g7 using the H file now two
blacks advantage Merck a7 Bishop c5 rook
takes f7 was wisp White's choice and now
white simply resigns the game of course
if if white had just moved the Rick out
of the way
Bishop takes f2 would be devastating
with Rick h8 quickly to follow and I
felt like this was a very very
instructive game for for Karpov here you
see both players ignoring each other
playing on the side of the board but on
opposite sides of the board but when it
really counts white missed his
opportunity to lock things down on the
Queen's side so always be on the lookout
in your games for ways to really slow
down your opponent's plan at the right
moment
that being said Karpov broke through won
the game and kudos to him for being the
first maybe unofficial world rapid
champion all the way back in 1988 with
that being said this was game review
thank you very much for joining me my
name is Caleb Denby and I will see you
in the next episode